[Musique]
faire des nouilles soba demande tout une
dextérité
le chef y abouta sait s'y prendre mon
père prenait le cours de production de
soba quand j'étais petit temps pour moi
c'est mon goût d'enfance cunico fujita
critique gastronomique devient
nostalgique lorsqu'elle nous parle des
nouilles soba
c'est pour cela que j'ai admiré dad
le chef y habitent ça m'a donné comme
une sorte nostalgie surtout cette année
mais thème place au bras voilà c'est le
grain de sarrasin qui donne le nom à la
nouille soba au japon soba en japonais
ça veut dire le coin pointus ou bien à
la pente la pente très raide c'est parce
que le crâne de sarrasin est en forme
triangulaire donc au pointu
c'est quoi la différence du domaine et
sont pas bons ce sont les 3 noeuds il
est plus populaire plus consommée au
japon
les romains ont fessé les nouilles
chinoises les nouilles ou dont c'est
fait seulement avec la farine de blé
avec toro tandis que les nouilles soba
s'est basé sur la farine de sarrasin
pour créer la pâte
la première étape est très importante
avec une minutie hors du commun
le chef ajoute de façon très progressive
de l'eau dans la farine composé de 80 %
de sarrasin et 20% de blé la préparation
est assez compris que ce n'est pas du
tout où les chiffres qui peuvent faire
ce n'est pas évident par exemple d'avoir
une somme a en même temps que les sushis
dans un seul le restant ce n'est pas
évident
dans les resto japonais traditionnels
les nouilles soba sont faites à la
commande
au fur et à mesure une opération qui
prend au minimum de 30 à 40 minutes
[Musique]
le chef étale la pâte avec des bâtons de
différentes grosseurs puis il lui donne
une forme carrée avant de la replier
plusieurs fois finalement avec un rythme
précis le chef y habitent à coop celle
ci pour en faire des nouilles ensuite il
met les nouilles dans l'eau chaude
pendant trente secondes puis les noms
ils sont plongés dans l'eau glacée pour
arrêter la cuisson
c'est la ronde de soba frêche qui est
extraordinaire c'est pour cela aussi
qu'on va au restaurant de soba on attend
assez longtemps mais c'est une attente
de plaisir les sodas sont servis simple
mais aussi avec quelques polars comme le
thé pour les viandes les champignons les
légumes sautés et on pouvait noter ce
genre de plat en prenant un peu de saké
aussi pardon mais pourquoi pas pourquoi
pas les nouilles soba sont également
servis en salade froide
bonjour j'ai cet été à salade se bat
pour l'appétit
[Musique]
le chef tatsuya shimizu du restaurant
marusan prépare une salade composée de
soba infusé au thé matcha une autre
belle façon de servir les nouilles
d'abord il prépare une sauce maison
vinaigre de riz bouillon dashi soya
n'irai pas de sésame huile de chili est
un peu de sucre japonais sur l'assiette
nappes et ils déposent les nouilles soba
la salade est composé de requêtes de
concombres d'oignons verts de nori et de
tomate rôtie cette salade chou bas peut
très bien être un plat principal ou un
accompagnement ni soif ni fracas selon
la coutume les soldats doivent être
aspiré et non porter à la bouche un
petit bout chez sonauto respecte chef
autonome de noise chose respect mais
voici en train d'essayer de rendre
hommage au chef
en épicerie on trouve surtout des
nouilles soba sèche de type sautonie
hachey composé de 20 % sarrazin et 80%
blé c'est vrai que c'est pratique et
puis aussi les japonais achètent
beaucoup à mesmont japon cunico suggère
de choisir les nouilles les plus film
pour se rapprocher du format des sodas
frêche
par exemple les ne sont très fines fait
nous l' apport armes ça au japon on aime
tellement les sauts bas qu on les offre
en cadeau au jour de la les nus soba
sont fines très fine mais assez longue
donc on souhaite aussi que vit même
modestement mais pendant longtemps
oh
[Musique]